على خطى سفينه تايتنك غرق غواصه تايتن قد
يدفع لاعاده النظر في سلامه الانظمه
البحريه فبعد غرق سفينه تايتنك في شمال
المحيط الاطلسي ظهرت عام
1914 الاتفاقيه الدوليه لسلامه الحياه في
البحر والتي لا تزال تحكم السلامه البحريه
حتى يومنا هذا
غرق الغواصه تايتن دفع خبراء السلامه
البحريه لبحث مساله تجديد الاجراءات
المحققون لاحظوا ان غواصه تايتن ابحرت ولم
تلتزم بالانظمه البحريه في المياه الدوليه
بينما يتساهل اصحاب الاختراعات
والمستكشفون مع انظمه السلامه يشدد
الخبراء على ضروره رفع مستوى السلامه
البحريه خصوصا للرحلات المدفوعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات